what's up guys welcome back to Cydonia
Hills in this video I'll work on the
beginnings of the Japanese area in the
park for which I'll make a pretty big
bnm inverts which is gonna be you know
sort of the main attraction of this
section of the park and because of that
I really wanted to make sure that I got
this right since much of the rest of the
layouts of the of this section is going
to be more or less loosely based around
the layouts for this coaster and in
reality there was a lot more trial and
error and messing with like different
ideas for layouts than you actually see
in the video here which is just the
building of the final layouts as it's
gonna be I was figuring for quite a
while I wanted to make a coaster kind of
like nemesis or black member a very long
to the ground kind of terrain conforming
inverted coaster but the end I kind of
found a balance between a more regular
inverted coaster on just a flatland with
pretty high drops and large inversions
but also a bit of the elements of those
terrain conforming coasters it does
start off kind of like a standard Batman
clone I kind of idea with pretty large
drop at the beginning a large loop into
a zero-g roll but the rest of the
layouts is a bit more twisty bit more
helixes and very tight curves and turns
and it's gonna follow the terrain quite
a bit so it's sort of a hybrid between
those two types of inverted coasters I
feel so you know it's still a very
sizeable and thrilling coaster but at
the same time hopefully it should be
able to fit quite nicely into the area
around it and it should be possible to
have some nice Rock work and very dense
scenery for the coaster to interact with
because in the end that was more or less
the idea I just wanted to make sure that
I could have a coaster which could fit
quite nicely in the Japanese theme and
not only have a Japanese theme but also
interact quite nicely with the scenery
around it now I did make it quite tricky
for myself when it comes to this station
though because there's a trek going
underneath the station and it's right
going over the station so I had to find
a good way to have that track be able to
go over it but at the same time have a
tracker underneath it while also having
the
which for the path go over that part of
the track it's a little bit more tight
than I was hoping for with this part of
the layout especially with how almost
out and back the layout is it's not as
you know really compact and twisting
around itself as you see with many
coasters but it kind of goes somewhere
with the lift Hill and go is almost
completely into another corner of this
theme with the like the section on the
left here so it's gonna go through
almost the entire Japanese area in the
end most likely but yeah the trucks kind
of meet underneath the station which was
a bit awkward to work with but I'm
actually quite happy with having these
station kind of sit on top of a hill
which one track can go underneath and
another track can go over to have some
extra interaction in there and there is
definitely enough space around this area
because in the end I do want this to
make to be like sort of the main part of
the Japanese area there is definitely
going to be all sorts of other small
squares and little places with some flat
rides and smaller restaurants but this
place with the station and the big
circle which you can see in the middle
of that square with the path which in
the future is going to be a pagoda I
kind of want this to be like the main
section of the park since this is where
two rides meet up and it's also whether
you station for this coaster is gonna be
so yeah there's a lot of guest flow
gonna be right here and that's why I
kind of wanted to turn this into like
the most interesting and busy part of
this area now it sure was really busy
with placing everything for the station
though because since it's like on top of
something while I also had something on
top of the station itself it was kind of
a struggle to see how I could actually
get this station in and not to mention
that there was one other big struggle
I've never actually built a Japanese
building in Park tech before but what I
already felt would be the most like the
biggest challenge with making Japanese
buildings in parka texts kind of comes
through to things but it basically just
boils down that it's - that it's really
hard to make it look Japanese I think
one issue is definitely that there are
no Japanese details there
not the you know the very typical
Japanese curved roofs that you think of
when you think of a Japanese theme the
walls are actually somewhat doable with
the the pillars and the white walls but
there we don't really have any of the
Japanese details that you would want to
look for but I think an even bigger
challenge is the fact that everything is
on these four grid squares and that goes
for the roofs as well and what you kind
of want to see with the Japanese
buildings is some roofs that kind of
stick out you know they don't stick out
that much but they kind of overhang from
the walls and the issue with that is
that I definitely wanted to have some
overhanging groups but with the building
system with full square roof tiles I had
to make the roof stick out a full tile
which seems fine at first but because of
the isometric view of the game it kind
of makes the rest of the building
invisible like if I would have just have
every roof you know stick out a full
tile you'd barely see any of the walls
of the building yet on the other hand if
I don't have the roof stick out at all
it's not gonna look very Japanese and I
figured a good way to get around those
issues would be to you know make the
roof in general stick out a full tile
but have these parts of the building
that kind of come out a bit so here you
can see at the end and the beginning of
the station and in these full tile sort
of I'm not really sure what you call
them there are in many Japanese
buildings like some walkways that you
see outside the building that stick out
quite a bit from the building and are
just below the overhanging roof and I
figured it would be a good way to get
some like extra pillars and walls
sticking out from underneath the roof
because as you can see without these
parts sticking out with their walls and
pillars you mostly see just roof for the
building and I just thought that
wouldn't be too interesting to look at
and yeah I think this was just a good
way to get around making these buildings
look Japanese without having you know to
use any Japanese details which we don't
have there are definitely some great
mods for it but since I'm playing this
on vanilla I just more or less how to
mess with the composition of the
buildings to make this work
which adds a bit of an extra challenge
to it as well because I already think
one of the most important things to
Japanese buildings is not just to get
Japanese details in but it's definitely
to get a Japanese sort of construction
composition of the building itself what
I very often see as like a major pitfall
to making Japanese buildings is people
using Japanese walls and roof types but
not a general Japanese composition of
buildings and Japanese buildings are
laid out very differently than Western
buildings I think you know a lot more
horizontally a lot more rectangular and
symmetrical like many of the European
buildings have a lot of focus and large
windows windows details like that but
low of the focus on Japanese buildings
is on the roof which is where most of
the detail and many horizontal accents
are and there are actually some major
functional differences that make you
know these buildings very different as
well like the fact that many Japanese
buildings don't have walls and windows
as you would see them with Western
buildings but just sliding paper panels
that you can use and it's just it just
makes the entire construction of the
buildings quite different which is why
composition in general makes you know a
Japanese building look so typically
Japanese even without considering the
Japanese detailing so that's something
that I at least wanted to get in here
though in general I would also probably
call this theme park Japanese because
much like many theme parks it's
definitely not entirely realistic and
I'm not the biggest well knower of
Japanese architecture in general so I'm
just trying to make it look as Japanese
as I can now one other one other thing
that I wanted to do here and it's get
some rock work and around the station
now I'll have a lot of rock work around
the entire ride but I think especially
in this case it's good to make like a
differentiation between two types of
rock work I think there's like the
detailing Rock work which you mainly use
to blend in or kind of glue together an
area and there's the like real
composition rock work the rock work that
you really use to
big mountains or big rocky facades and I
think this is definitely the detailing
type it's just smaller real quick I'm
not really actually changing the shape
of these hills too much I try to get
these rocks as close to the hills as I
can just wanted to use them to blend the
station together a bit with the
environments because especially because
this station is located right on top of
this valley which the coaster is going
underneath it kind of felt that without
the rocks the station wasn't really
connected to the rest of the area it
just kind of set on top of this little
hill that doesn't really blend in with
the rest of the scenery I have run here
and I think just by having these rocks
you know I can make the station a bit
more part of the area make it come a bit
close to the paths and a bit more like
it's actually supported by these Rock
work kind of facades that you know come
out on the sides of the coaster now I'll
definitely we'll get into the big
construction rock work on the rest of
the ride to actually make some big rocky
facades and really steep hills but
that's something I'll get into in the
next episode so I won't talk too much
about that now the next thing that I
wanted to do in this video and I am
pretty sure it's also the last thing is
at the transfer track for the coaster
which to be very honest I am NOT the
biggest transfer track knower either
just kind of figured I wanted to have
that transfer track over here it's
pretty large coaster and especially with
coasters of the sides of this side you
this size you want to run two trains and
you want to be able to store that one
other train in case you know you need to
store it somewhere which is often either
if it needs maintenance
I figure or very often if it's not on a
really but busy day and you don't really
need to run two trains and for that
reason I wanted to make that quick
transfer track which is quite simple I
didn't really find any other way to add
any of the machinery around transfer
tracks that you would really love to see
but I also wanted to make a small
building to actually store the car in
nice and dry when you don't need to use
the car so other train I should say so I
wanted to make a small building over
here now since this is
an isometric game in the end and I did
want everything to look quite nice even
the backstage area which truth be told
there are not going to be any guests in
this area since you know it's just for
staff but I don't want to still make
this building look quite nice and make
it fit in with the rest of the theme and
hence why I wanted to turn this into a
small simple Japanese storage building
and the idea is largely the same as the
station building just a rectangular base
with woodwork and some walls on top of
which I wanted to have a square roof I
didn't want one part to kind of stick
out throughout or toward the station
that is since between the station and
the transfer track I wanted to have like
one small backstage kind of Plaza which
I won't turn into a mess like
realistically it would probably just be
used for storage and be riddled with
garbage and containers and whatnot but
just for this case I wanted to
realistically have that bit of backstage
area but not make it you know too big
just kind of have it there in terms of
you know the layout of the park and
wanting it there for realism purposes
but there is no way to actually renovate
with any of the things that you would
kind of realistically want to see
besides I also figured that it would fit
in with the general philosophy of the
park which is that I didn't want to make
something which you know does come out
of the game it's a bit inspired by the
parks in Rolla Coast icon 1 & 2 for
instance but it still has some aspects
of realism so just for the game I am
since it is an isometric game I wanted
to have you know detail and scenery just
about everywhere and not go too far with
Park realism like realistically I would
only have to make facades of buildings
and put grey boxes behind that which is
also something that I'm avoiding in this
case I guess the same just goes for
backstage areas like this want to have
them for realism purposes but stings
since you always have to look at them
since there is only an isometric
perspective especially since I'm not
using any mods right now
I did at least once we turn this into
something that's alright to look at and
besides I guess there is also the
coaster track going over to this quite
neatly and I didn't want to you know
blend this in with the rest of the
coaster
quite a bit it's gonna be a pretty
densely themed coaster I won't have any
buildings around it
but it'll make its way through like a
forest through a lot of rock work guess
that's not entirely tensely themed it's
more about the scenery around this
coaster but um I didn't want to make
sure that it didn't turn out to be one
of these Six Flags empty parking lot
kind of courses idea this was actually
kind of funny for a bit here I was
placing trees in pulse mode and I'll
definitely continue to do so for a while
but what they actually do in pulse mode
for some reason which is a bug in the
current build at least at the time is I
wanted to you know place these trees
down and they always make this bit of a
jiggle as you placed them and I guess in
pulse mode for while the gravity just
made them completely fall to the ground
which is a little bit awkward but not
too big of an issue but yeah for the
rest of the scenery over here it's just
wanting to have a little bit of
gardening on the topic of which I do
want to you know have a bit of a custom
biome for the Japanese area Akuma when
you compare it to the rest of the park
much like in the Alpine area I wanted to
have some extra spruces and in the Roman
area I wanted to have some extra
tsipras's there are technically poplars
but you know they kind of come in two
surfaces there anyway and in this area I
will try to make the foliage just a
little bit more Japanese just a bit
though and for the rest of the foliage
to keep it quite similar to the rest of
the park so I do want to use quite a few
more of these round bushes which is a
bit of a Japanese garden thing and maybe
some more colored trees like some red
and yellow trees and that'll be like the
general foliage for this part of the
park
anyway I am running out of time maps for
this episode so thank you guys for
watching and I hope to see you guys in
the next episode in which I'll be making
a forest some rock work and some small
restaurants in this area of the park